al principio de la semana alfredo tenía
un saldo de menos 15 pesos con 8
centavos en su cuenta de banco el lunes
por la mañana depositó un cheque por 426
pesos con 90 centavos el martes por la
mañana depositó otro cheque por 100
pesos cuánto dinero hay en su cuenta de
banco después del segundo depósito bien
así que para empezar alfredo le debe
dinero al banco alfredo tiene un saldo
negativo así que sobre giro de su cuenta
y le debe dinero al banco así que vamos
a empezar con menos 15.08 pesos y ese es
nuestro saldo inicial a eso le vamos a
sumar
vamos a sumar el primer depósito que es
de 426 pesos con 90 centavos 426 puntos
90 y otro depósito de 100 pesos más 100
ok esto es lo mismo que si consideramos
que empezamos con 15.08 pesos negativos
y le sumamos esto de aquí consideramos
los dos depósitos como uno solo y esto
cuánto nos da cuatrocientos 26.9 más 100
es 526 puntos 90 pesos
ok vamos a dibujar nuestra recta
numérica para poder visualizar qué está
pasando vamos a decir que eso de ahí es
nuestra recta numérica y que el 0 está
digamos aquí
ok si empezamos con menos 15.08 pesos
eso quiere decir que estamos 15.08
unidades a la izquierda del 0 ya no
estamos por aquí está el 15.08 más bien
dicho al menos 15.08 ok y ahora le vamos
a sumar 526 pesos 526 pesos con 90
centavos
partiendo del final de la flecha
amarilla voy a sumar 526 pesos con 90
centavos y esto obviamente en nuestra
escala ok entonces cuánto dinero le
queda alfredo pues le queda del 0
el final de esta flecha morada
y eso qué longitud tiene pues tiene 526
15.08 de hecho lo puede escribir así
esto es 526
punto 90
menos
y sumar un negativo equivale a restar un
positivo así que menos
15.08
y ahora sólo tengo que hacer esa cuenta
cuánto es 500 26.90 menos
15.08
pero es menor que 8 así que voy a tomar
un uno prestado este 9 se convierte en
un 8 este 0 se convierte en un 10 10
menos ocho es 28 - 0 es 8
6 5 es 1 y 2 - 1 es 150 5 así que esta
longitud la cantidad de dinero que tiene
alfredo en su cuenta de banco es de 511
pesos con 82 centavos